este debate sobre el estado de la nación
se ha hecho esperar desde 2015 por
varios motivos por un lado el hecho de
que no se suelen hacer cuando coinciden
con año electoral y es que en españa ha
habido tres comicios generales entre
2016 y 2019 en 2020 como bien sabemos
llegó la pandemia de kobe 19 que
paralizó toda actividad política 2022
retome así esta cita parlamentaria de
tres días que inició con el discurso de
una hora y veinte del presidente pedro
sánchez que anunció medidas para
combatir el impacto de una inflación que
en españa alcanza el 10,2 por ciento una
cifra que él ha achacado a la guerra en
ucrania y que ha dicho ningún gobierno
podría haber resuelto de la noche a la
mañana entre estos anuncios están los
abonos para el tren gratuitos en el
último trimestre del año e impuestos
sobre los llamados beneficios caídos del
cielo para las grandes eléctricas y
también impuestos sobre los beneficios
de entidades bancarias recibidos por la
subida de los tipos de interés ambas
medidas recaudarían a 2024 3.500
millones de euros y han recibido la
aprobación de los socios de coalición de
gobierno que pedían desde hacía semanas
un viraje a la izquierda en las
políticas
es del ejecutivo la oposición por su
parte recriminó al gobierno la falta de
autocrítica con estos anuncios sánchez
espera suavizar los roces con sus socios
y terminar así una legislatura que está
prevista acabaría a finales de 2023
cuando se convoquen nuevas elecciones